this video is brought to you by wren
[Music]
what's up everybody michael here i don't
know about you but in this chaotic world
i've found there's no better cure for
ongoing feelings of dread then nope not
a carton of cherry garcia but some
dopamine inducing videos of people
acting like dogs i'm talking about
tick-tock as of last year the app had 1
billion active users making it one of
the largest and fastest growing social
media platforms but as the app and it's
algorithm become more ubiquitous we're
learning in real time how it's affecting
our society and even our brains and some
worry it's doing so for the worse who
created the airfryer really
really because i can't do it anymore are
these concerns legit or a tad overblown
let's find out in this wisecrack edition
is tick tock evil but before we dive in
i want to tell you about this video
sponsor ren
when i look at the news lately things
are
not great in a lot of ways but among
them is the ever looming threat of
climate disaster and it's easy to feel
helpless but ren is an easy way to help
turn your concern for the climate into
tangible action first ren's easy quiz
helps you calculate the exact size of
your carbon footprint they'll ask you
about things like your diet your travel
habits and other lifestyle basics from
there they suggest ways for you to
reduce your impact on the environment
right off the bat
for instance i should really stop
driving short distances to pick up
things like burritos when i could just
walk but because nobody's carbon
footprint can be zero rent also offsets
your remaining footprint with their
targeted climate initiatives as someone
who lives in california i was really
impressed with wren's biochar project
which removes dead trees from redwood
forest and high fire risk areas they
turn these trees into biochar a stable
form of carbon that lasts for thousands
of years and while i'm extra pumped
about ren's projects that are local to
me their work resonates around the world
there's their mineral weathering project
in scotland for instance which turns
atmospheric carbon into solid rock all
using accelerated natural geological
processes which is cool and all but this
project also includes a brigade of
woolly pigs who prepare the soil for
regrowth and they are just so adorable
once you sign up to make a monthly
contribution that will be used to offset
your carbon footprint you'll receive
monthly updates from the projects you
support so you will actually see the
impact that you were making rent is
pledged to plant 10 extra trees for the
first 100 people who sign up using our
referral link so go to
dot co slash start slash wisecrack to
join us in saving the rainforest and
fighting the climate crisis that's ren
dot co slash start slash wisecrack and
now back to the show there's a lot of
debate about whether tick-tock is a
societal good or societal evil on the
downside it's been shown to increase
anxiety depression and body image issues
and oh i don't know it also allows a
chinese company to collect your personal
data and possibly maybe collude with the
chinese government for fun censorship or
propaganda reasons then again facebook
misinformation played a key role in
influencing elections but hey who's
keeping score but tiktok isn't all bad
it's great for making friends and
expanding your community of people with
niche interest like
midwest mom cooking hacks plus it's an
accessible creative outlet that's super
entertaining look at the butterfly
that looks stupid i mean where else
could you see this
[Applause]
or this i added these tassels to it and
our lives have never been the same or
this
i could go on for literal hours but i'll
stop now and it's this level of
addiction that sets tic-tac apart from
other social media platforms tik-tok has
a top-of-the-line algorithm that
consistently gives you what you want
this never-ending quest for dopamine is
what some researchers now refer to as
tic-tac-brain
and parents and experts are worried
about the impact it has on kids
shrinking attention spans tick tock
hasn't been around long enough for
researchers to discern whether it
permanently alters or damages kids
brains but we couldn't help but notice
these concerns are reminiscent of
debates over whether violent video games
cause increased aggression or whether
heavy metal gives you an unquenchable
thirst for goat blood so is it possible
we're projecting our deeply embedded
societal fears onto tick-tock odds are
yes fear almost always rides on the
coattails of new technology for example
plato and socrates both believed writing
would destroy the oral tradition and
make everyone forgetful when trains were
first invented everyone thought
centrifugal force would make women's
uteruses fly out they they didn't do
that and in the late 19th century
experts warned that riding a bicycle
could result in bicycle face a condition
where your face would permanently look
blown back by a mighty wind there was
even a cnn article published in 2005
that said email hurt the iq more than
marijuana these hypotheses all beg the
question why are we so freaked out by
technology and is tick-tock the latest
centrifugal uterus-ejecting force in
human development prior to the 18th
century science and technology were
separate non-threatening entities
science was mostly based in heady
theories while technology was composed
of skills passed down through the
generations like blacksmithing or
cobbling then in a classic rom-com meat
cute scenario 18th century scientists
priestly and lavacier introduced these
fields to each other via chemical
discoveries that led to large-scale
electricity just like that science had
practical applications and technology
had a role in scientific progress they
completed each other by the beginning of
the 19th century everyone was hyped on
this new technology thing scientists and
craftsmen intersected to create the
engineer and the world seemed full of
possibilities flying machines submarines
and the ability to talk to the dead were
surely just around the corner right
technology transformed into a cure-all
for the human condition society and the
world which is exactly how i used to
feel about improv yes and much like
improv the movement picked up cult level
enthusiasm it became known as positivism
auguste conti a french philosopher and
positivist dreamed of a utopian society
where all the best scientists were in
power and that they unified everyone
through scientific and political
progress if that were true today we'd be
reciting the scientific method instead
of the pledge of allegiance which when i
really think about it wouldn't be so bad
unfortunately before this utopia could
take shape people's enthusiasm and
excitement for technology took a turn
for the worse the start of the
industrial revolution kicked off a rise
in collective tech anxiety the landscape
of people's lives literally and
figuratively seemed to transform
overnight the new bourgeois emerged and
as they profited off new technologies
they didn't promote peace fairness and
equality like people expected instead
they scooped up their money without
regard for how it affected people around
them meanwhile workers were afraid of
losing their jobs to machines and didn't
have any social protections if that did
happen people's anxiety over tech boiled
down to three big questions one could
technology be destructive in the hands
of the wrong people two could this power
make humans into gods and three could
humans be automated out of a job or
purpose
then a couple of world wars came around
you may have heard of them and answered
those first two questions with a
resounding yes it became crystal clear
that humans could and would use science
and technology to kill millions of
people while the rise of the internet in
silicon valley revived a vision of
technological utopia anxiety surrounding
tech would never vanish completely
something about lightning fast
innovation continues to freak a lot of
us out philosophers included martin
heidegger a german philosopher who we
must note was in the nazi party was one
of the first thinkers to associate
technology with the devastation of
humanity's desire for truth and meaning
heidegger theorized that technology
pulls us away from the true meaning of
human existence which he called dazine
which describes our way of being in the
world always marked by the fact that our
being is oriented towards our inevitable
finitude i.e our death in other words
heidegger thought that when we stop
looking for meaning in things like art
and poetry and instead rely on
technology to make sense of the world
things start to have a primarily
instrumental value the next generation
of german philosophers doubled down on
this idea the frankfurt school theorized
that post-war capitalist societies could
become a kind of invisible
totalitarianism founded on the
domination of technology-fueled
consumerism people would slowly lose
their willpower and be controlled
through the manipulation of their
desires you know like how tick-tock does
jurgen habermas one of the last living
members of the frankfurt school believed
technology has its own logic and
threatens to destroy not only politics
culture and human life but the world
because again technology can pull us
away from both the essence of our human
subjectivity and our desire to find
meaning beyond profit and productivity
but as it turns out technology hasn't
destroyed everything yet
except for my relationship with my uncle
rob after he kept posting on facebook we
can now communicate with far-flung
friends and family more easily than ever
before which is rad again except for
with my uncle rob we can have a
life-saving bacon egg and cheese sent to
our homes with the tap of a button as we
ride in bed hung over hell you can even
get a pacemaker that tracks your cardiac
health and sends potentially life-saving
status updates to your doctor but in
spite of countless net positive
developments new innovations like tic
tac can still freak us out and the
anxiety around tech is alive and well
and some of this is valid for one social
media and other database innovations
collect circulate share and profit off
of our data on a global level it's scary
when our personal data is used for
purposes outside of our control it's
double scary when tick-tock's algorithm
can so accurately predict and control
our behavior if technology can make us
watch cat videos for hours
what's to stop it from taking over our
lives completely and what happens when
the videos it serves us aren't just fun
time wasters but less fun conspiracy
theories now obviously misinformation
clogs up every social media platform as
the uncle robbs of the facebook world
unite to convince you that there's now a
microchip in your happily vaccinated arm
but journalist and author chris stokel
walker argues that tick tock's algorithm
coupled with the immediacy of its format
makes it especially ripe for
misinformation he writes emotive videos
can cause people to overlook whether or
not information is legitimate this can
have real consequences analysis from
media firm newsguard determined that
misinformation about covid reached a
staggering eight out of nine children
after just 35 minutes on the app many
adults are concerned in particular about
potentially misleading videos on what's
known as therapy talk this is a trend in
which gen z self-diagnosis mental
disorders after watching influencers
videos chronicling their own struggles
experts are split on whether this is
good or bad on the one hand influencers
help normalize discussions around mental
health but on the other misdiagnosing
mental health issues can have serious
consequences to say nothing about the
apps that are making it easier than ever
for young people to get psych meds they
may or may not need sent directly to
their homes however what's at the crux
of this issue is our very human tendency
to trust popular people even if they
have no idea what they're talking about
historically the most popular people
around have been celebrities and the
masses have loved following their
examples whether they're channeling
their inner lord byrons with roughly
shirts raising aids awareness like bono
and angelina jolie or drinking high-end
tequila because george clooney and his
buddies make it but celebrity influence
can also backfire remember jenny
mccarthy well back in 2005 she used her
expertise as a parent to widely
propagate the idea that the mmr vaccine
caused her son's autism even today you
might have noticed that many americans
still aren't sure about vaccines but
whether you're turning to tom brady for
nutritional advice j-lo for her hair
care routine or buying a subway foot
long because steph curry told you to at
the end of the day celebrities they're
just like us is a punch line for a
reason they are not like us so where
does a feeling of true trust and kinship
exist in today's media landscape tick
tock of course where folks who are just
like you
are able to have a celebrity-like
influence just by virtue of being
themselves as you take in the sheer
volume of content from your favorite
creators it's easy to form what's called
a parasocial relationship with them i.e
one in which you feel like you already
know that person in real life even
though they have no idea you exist
what's more scholars bendari and bimo
suggested in their analysis of tick-tock
that in contrast to other social media
platforms the crux of interaction is not
between users and their social network
but between a user and what we call an
algorithmized version of self so
essentially tick tock compounds these
parasocial relationships with such
algorithmic precision but not only are
you looking at your favorite creator but
it also feels like you're looking into a
mirror
at yourself you might be asking yourself
why are we as a human race predisposed
to listening to celebrities and
influencers instead of qualified experts
well there are evolutionary and
psychological reasons behind why we
trust who we trust as far as influencers
are concerned we often fall victim to
prestige biased social learning in basic
terms this is the tendency to trust and
learn from people who have gained
attention respect and admiration for
success in a particular domain in this
case
tick tock subscribers and views this
adaptive social learning strategy
developed as a shortcut to identifying
group members who are thriving without
needing to assess a 16 year old
superstar's individual merits so is
potentially harmful and dangerous
misinformation being spread on tick tock
absolutely but again this isn't unique
to tiktok and genzir's reliance on
therapy talk for advice and guidance
isn't what's standing in the way of them
seeking mental health care as many have
pointed out inaccessibility to mental
health care is what drives young people
to therapy talk for answers in the first
place so far tick-tock doesn't seem
particularly evil but what about
tick-tock sides aka little niche
communities or echo chambers on the app
could these result in greater political
polarization not really ironically
political polarization currently occurs
most in generations that use social
media the least aka the olds plus
political polarization has been growing
in the u.s since the 1970s long before
noodles ever had a no bones day but hey
it's a lot easier to blame tick tock
than to address the real problems behind
polarization like
growing income equality lack of access
to education resistance to
multiculturalism and globalization
stagnant wages and taco bell continuing
to tease us with the return of the
mexican pizza so then tick tock could
and probably does cause polarization but
it's probably not the main culprit in
other words human behavior may be to
blame and that makes us uncomfortable so
we use tick-tock as a scapegoat for
serious societal issues for example
there are lots of studies floating
around arguing that social media
increases anxiety depression and poor
self-esteem the problem is many of those
are correlational researchers sort
people into two groups people who
consume tick-tock and people who suffer
from anxiety and depression then they
check the venn diagram to see who's at
the center if it's enough people eureka
tick-tock must cause all sorts of mental
illnesses yeah but not really
correlational studies only tell us these
two groups are interconnected they don't
tell us whether tick-tock or depression
is the chicken or the egg but
longitudinal studies on social media do
these aren't as common because
longitudinal studies take more time and
money and unless you're santa claus it's
not exactly cheap to track thousands of
kids over the years however researchers
from brigham young university finland
and canada were able to secure the
funding for this very purpose and found
no true correlation between social media
and anxiety and depression conversely
german and canadian studies found
depressed and or anxious people were
more likely to use social media and that
depressive symptoms could even predict
social media usage this could indicate
that people dealing with mental
illnesses might be drawn to the hyper
stimulation dopamine rewards and so on
that social media facilitates all of
this strongly suggests that our
society's anxiety and depression is the
chicken and social media is the egg so
yes tik tok is absolutely changing the
social media landscape but it's not
fundamentally changing us in a tale as
old as time we've hyper focused on
technology and ignored the power of our
own psychology to be clear we're not
trying to say that tick-tock is a
societal good as we discussed in our
previous episode on elon's potential
acquisition of twitter calling platforms
good or bad is kind of missing the point
tick-tock is used by influencers and
wannabe influencers it's used by nurses
teachers and therapists it's also used
by say radical extremists however the
knee-jerk reaction to judge it as
inherently evil or dangerous is
misguided a more apt description might
be tick-tock is chaotic neutral the
reality is the tick tock is a free
product whose chief source of income is
ad revenue and the only way to increase
that income is to keep people on the app
for as long as possible our attention is
a valuable resource and boy oh boy is it
in demand in this new attention economy
focus is our scarcest and most valuable
resource so how do we keep social media
companies like tic tock from stealing it
right out of our time wallets author
mark manson proposes an attention diet
where we identify worthwhile information
in relationships cut out the junk and
cultivate habits that foster deeper
focus and longer attention spans the
goal is to focus on what adds value to
your life by being more intentional
about what we consume on social media
and how long we spend there this is
obviously easier said than done but
maybe just maybe if we can build our
mental fortitude like we build our
imaginary investment portfolios we might
just be able to beat the algorithm after
all but what do you guys think can we
win our attention back from the world's
most effective algorithm do we even want
our attention back if it means being
bored as [ __ ] let us know what you think
in the comments big thanks to our
patrons for all your support and be sure
to check out our new patreon features
also check out our new stream wisecrack
live it happens every thursday 11am
pacific hit that subscribe button like
you're tapping the do not disturb button
and touch in some grass and don't forget
to ring that bell as always thanks for
watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you